l'amérique
avance mais nous ne pouvons pas nous arrêter
maintenant nous sommes en concurrence avec la chine et d'
autres pays
pour gagner le 21e siècle nous sommes à un grand
point d'inflexion
de l'histoire nous devons faire plus que
reconstruire mieux
nous reconstruisons nous
nous devons mieux reconstruire nous devons être
plus compétitifs que maintenant
après seulement 100 jours je peux signaler à la
nation l'
amérique est de nouveau en mouvement le
plan américain pour l'emploi va créer des
millions d'emplois bien rémunérés des emplois les
américains peuvent élever une famille sur
comme dirait mon père alors avec un peu de
répit
et tous les investissements dans le
plan d'emploi américain seront guidés par un principe
par américain par l'amérique
commençons par ce que je ne
ferai pas je n'imposerai aucune augmentation d'impôt aux
personnes gagnant moins
de  quatre cent mille dollars,
mais il est temps pour les entreprises américaines
et le 1% des américains les plus riches
vient de commencer à payer leur
juste part
juste leur juste part l'Amérique
résistera au commerce déloyal  pratiques et
saper les travailleurs
américains dans les industries américaines comme les subventions
de l'État aux opérations et
entreprises publiques
et le vol de
la propriété intellectuelle de la technologie américaine
j'ai également dit au président xi que nous
maintiendrons une forte présence militaire dans
l'indo-
pacifique comme nous le faisons  pour l'otan et l'europe non pas pour
déclencher un conflit mais pour en empêcher un
dans ma discussion en tant que président xi je lui ai dit
que nous accueillons la concurrence
nous ne recherchons pas de conflit mais j'ai
clairement indiqué
que nous défendrons les intérêts de l'amérique à
tous les niveaux
en ce qui concerne  russie je sais que cela concerne
certains d'entre vous
mais j'ai dit très clairement à poutine que
nous n'allons pas chercher
excusez-moi l'escalade
mais leurs actions auront des conséquences
elles s'avèrent vraies et elles
se sont avérées vraies
mais ce soir je peux dire
grâce à vous, le peuple américain,
nos progrès ces cent derniers jours
contre l'une des pires pandémies de l'
histoire
ont été l'une des plus grandes réalisations logistiques
réalisations logistiques que ce pays ait
jamais vues mes compatriotes américains,
nous devons nous unir pour rétablir la
confiance entre les forces de l'ordre et les
personnes qu'ils servent
pour éradiquer le racisme systémique dans notre
système de justice pénale
et pour promulguer une réforme de la police au nom de george
floyd
qui a déjà passé la maison je  savons que les
républicains ont leurs propres idées
et sont engagés dans des discussions très productives
avec les démocrates au sénat,
nous devons travailler ensemble pour trouver un
consensus, mais faisons-le le mois prochain
pour le premier anniversaire de la mort de George Floyd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]